das ich überlegt habe nur 13.000 ist ein
richtiges dort meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren zurück aus den
vereinigten staaten und wieder zu ihren
diensten darum die größten scheiß clips
das internet zu verarschen eine runde
applaus bitte für ja ich habe schon von
dem professionellen nachrichtensprecher
und dann solle über eine woche in new
york sind jetzt auch wieder da und haben
direkt ein ekelhaftes video für euch
gefunden das uns heute anschauen werden
und auseinandernehmen werden zu meiner
linken sitzt wie immer montana black
ich habe gesehen leute das in meiner
abwesenheit ein video angekommen ist ein
video das an ihren losigkeit kaum zu
überbieten ist und zwar geht es um das
wunderbare produkt gold digger auch zeit
meine freundin treibt mich in den ruinen
neues verfahren alina und sören sind
seit einem jahr verlobt sie wollen drei
monaten heiraten der schon gesehen
das ist der stinktier first class nicht
glaubst du diesen menschen stehen dir
was stinkt hier aussieht also ich finde
hier zum beispiel er ist schon eine
gewisse ähnlichkeit da alina sieht sich
mit ihrer besten freundin vivien im
brautmoden laden um ihr verlobter soll
selbstverständlich 10 aline ihr
verlobter selbst nicht salami ihr
verlobter soll selbstverständlich zur
marine
ihr verlobter selbstverständlich zahlen
ja also klar wofür ist der abstand auf
der welt der zum zahlen
ihr verlobter soll selbstverständlich
zur alina ist in ihrem element
die designerkleider haben es ihr ganz
besonders angetan wird der
sprecherstimme ist halt schneller
gemacht und ich denke so ein bisschen
hören ja die designerkleider haben es
ihr ganz besonders angetan
kostenpunkt je teurer desto besser
perfekt doch meistens meine überlegung
wenn ich ihn irgendwann geht klar du
kannst du ihm geben oder bei netten
bananen für 150 kaufen
ich bin nicht dumm wenn ich die anderswo
auch für 20 euro kaufen kann besser
wurden natürlich auch die perücke von ti
und nicht von friseurinnen es stimmt
hier christlichen garten geschlichen hat
überfallen erwischt 1000 euro 6000 euro
aber mal ganz ehrlich ich glaube der typ
hat kein leichtes leben ohne witzig da
besteht nicht mehr langweilig ist bei
der tour de france herren arbeiten
musste muss rund um die uhr abhalten
bestätigte zu versorgen kleine rohde
[Musik]
ja nur 0 19 zehntausender kostet 10.000
euro für ein kleid alter du geistig
stück hier vor allem der kanal am ende
hilft mir junge leute verzweifelt
fachleute ich kann nur 10.000 euro für
nachverpflichtungen helwig 10.000 10.000
euro 10.000 folge er musicals und
einfach gehalten
ich finde das lächerlich du blöde sau
2000 wie bekloppt also ganz kurz warum
warum warum solche glaubt sei nicht ihr
habt nur 13.000 zur verfügung das ist
doch alles halb so schlimm halb so
schlimm
ich hab's dir gesagt lasst es mich so
teuer während die handlichkeit habe ich
doch nicht dass es nicht das teuerste
klein in der koalition besitzt auch also
argumentativ kanal zerstören
du hast du erst irgendwann warum sich
das ich haben 80 prozent der hochzeiten
kosten zwischen 4 und 7000 euro
das hatte auch seinen taschenrechner
nachgestellt und rechtsanwälten die
haben so einen eigenen computer effekte
mal gebiete also tablet und da können ja
immer so was machen
hilf mir könnt ihr mich irgendwie so ein
finanzberater rechtsanwalt was jetzt
tipps zu kosten waren auch zeiten geben
weil da nicht einfach genug
wir werden das in deutschland hat
natürlich immer einen vergoldeten
königshofen und redet berlinerisch was
machst kannst du dir keine andere sehen
das ist echt so bald sein kontostand
zehn millionen überschreitet wechselt
direkt von münchen oder aber da ich
liebe diese position heiraten hinterland
nicht sondern emotional system also dass
eltern wollen die verbieten dass du
diese frau hat den goldenen thron
den nehme ich mit doch mal hier weil ich
fragen wollte vielleicht 10.000 euro
land können 10.000 euro
der vater ist kein problem da hören wir
haben einfach einfach besser der
theoretisch sind die muttersprache
schnell über die schöne anleihen der ist
der tag der die mutter ist so auch im
gerade das ist einfach für mich aber
natürlich könnten wir das geld geben
nehmen sie von rtl kamerateams unterwegs
schon wieder gesagt dass doch so wie wir
hier ist es nicht aufgefallen bisher
sie passt wieder in unsere familie noch
in unseren stand noch in unser haus
steht dann so aus und immer sein stand
in widrigen jahrhundert analysen gefilmt
am 16
folge die passt nicht und so fällt es
wird sagen merkst du denn nicht dass
dieses mädchen nur an dein geld will
oder an unser geld besser gesagt das
klingt doch ganz die 10.000 euro jetzt
geben oder nicht ich hab nen scheiß dazu
war aber der fall nicht aber auch mal
ganz ehrlich gesagt ja ok man könnte
jetzt argumentieren oder auch argumente
eingehen und eine diskussion anfangen
aber ganz ehrlich geht aber die
schokolade nicht für dieses fleckchen
ihr werdet mir meine brot ja ist ja nur
meine freunde sondern um eine frau also
wäre es auch heiraten wenn ich in
deutschland nicht sagen einfach einfach
einfach einfach von sören sorge natalina
nichts für sie ist die traumhochzeit
gesetzt irgendwas einer stimme spreche
nicht über den youtube akteure sorgen an
tallinn lila nichts für sie ist die
traumhochzeit gesehen und sind damit
einverstanden mit der hochzeit auch und
dass wir auch dieses geld kino ja okay
wir haben sind ich sagen dass diese
jetzt nicht allein die machen dadurch
mit weil ich selbst mache das ist
schwachsinn so viel geld auf dem konto
da können wir ruhig etwas überraschen
lassen habe ich noch gesagt weißt aber
die sind aber wo sind die gerade ein
paar schleift sind die gryphon gold
könig studiert haben einmal die
holzhütte an dass ich überlegt habe ich
hab nur 13.000 ist richtig ist offen
dafür
jetzt irgendwie keine ahnung wer einfach
belauschen googles erste bildet so dass
ich überlegt habe ich hab mal 13.000 wie
sieht's mit ihr aus wenn sie etwas zu
steuern ich habe kein geld ich verdient
1000 euro im monat von was euch in der
geld sparen mein dispo situation nichts
hast du ja du hast nichts gar nichts du
denn hier besteht für 10.000 für den
kleinsten was auch immer und ganz kurz
auch die hose klar so eine hose ist ganz
klassischer fall von söhnen von
millionärs familien die haben in der
regel solch große anders mit mindestens
30 taschen wo sonst das geld hin machen
bestimmt ich muss mir noch ein habe ich
liebe dich und danach gehen die mich
meinen vorträgen tanja obwohl es den
finanziellen rahmen deutlich sprengt hat
während seiner braut das gleich für
10.000 euro zugesagt das heißt er hat
jetzt nur noch 3000 euro von seinem
ersparten übrig doch alinas ansprüche
werden nicht kleiner
ganz im gegenteil der verkäufer auch ich
bekomme auch sein gesicht
[Musik]
das wäre ja geführt wenn der lehrer den
du hast dich so begrüßt und du überhaupt
keinen bock hat jetzt nur noch warum
machen wir nicht mehr angeschaut ist
nicht wahr dass da versucht freundlich
zu sein dass es etwas wind nicht so ein
experte rät seinen tiefpunkt
menschen dürfen sich in der entdeckt
wenn er hat jetzt nur noch drei den
ringen da sind wir schon 2000 euro etwa
wo ist die redaktion hochzeitskleid was
man einmal an die 10.000 bring 1000
komplett behindert also meiner meinung
nach menschen abstoßend also die
schlechte die sind auf stimmen aus
diesen noch nicht verarbeitet
sie wollen auch sehen dass ich
verschiedene suntinger
wie fällt dann auch beide sind wir
rücken nicht nur die kunden habe man
irgendwann mit lügen muss los mit dir
gemacht habt was du dich richtig ist
eindruck von den freunden habe damit
diese person auch heutzutage vielleicht
hast du die klasse und mache aber noch
einen käufer
wir mussten lernen und zu verkaufen
kündigt allerdings wittert
ich war draußen und was den geltendes
recht zu beantworten hat einmal jetzt
auf einmal gesunder sekunde 5000 mal an
meinen fingern haben real was ist ein
brief werde jetzt jemand immer so ein
kopf an kopf rennen
wir machen kritisch ok also soll er wie
geplant fertig der kasse aber die leute
so kleine smog hat für euch leute so
wird es dann aus diesen drei anbringt
und hier daher sind wir wieder leute das
wird jetzt schon wieder zu erlangen und
ich habe noch weitere 30 minuten
rohmaterial deswegen zeigt das video
wieder in zwei teile auch das ist der
erste teil 2 kommt morgen um 18 uhr
damit zu lange warten müssen also schaut
morgen vorbei und check bis morgen hier
noch einen für euch vorschreiben das
video abkippen